the goal of this video is to explore
some of the concepts or formulas you
might see in a traditional physics class
but even more importantly to see that
they're really just common-sense ideas
so let's just let's just start with a
simple example let's say that and for
the sake of this video just so I stop
don't have to keep saying this is the
magnitude of the velocity this is the
direction of the velocity etc etc let's
just assume that if I have a positive
number that it means for example if I
have a positive velocity it means that I
am going to the right and let's say if I
have a negative number which we won't
see in this video let's assume that I'm
going to the left and that way I can
just write a number down we're only
operating in one dimension you know that
it's specifying both the magnitude and
the direction if I say the velocity is
five meters per second that means five
meters per second to the right if I say
it's negative five meters per second
that means it's five meters per second
to the left now let's just say just for
simplicity let's just say that we start
with an initial velocity we start with
an initial velocity of five meters per
second and once again I am specifying
about the magnitude and the direction
because of this convention here we know
it is to the right and let's say that we
have a constant acceleration we have a
constant acceleration at play of two
meters per second per second or two
meters per second squared and once again
since this is positive it is to the
right and let's say that we do this for
a duration so my change in time is let's
say we do this for a duration of four oh
four I'll use the same four I'll just
use s so I don't use seconds and then
second then s different places so s for
this video is seconds so what I want to
do is think about how far how far do we
travel and well there's two things that
how far how fast are we going after four
seconds and how far have we traveled
over the course of those four seconds so
let's draw a little drawer ourselves a
little bit of a diagram here so this is
my velocity axis and this over here is
my time axis I can draw a straighter
line than that so that is my time axis
time this is velocity it's clipping off
the left hand that is my velocity right
over there
I'm starting off at five meters per
second so this is five meters per second
right over here so VI is equal to five
meters per second and then every second
that goes by I'm going to meters per
second faster because this is two meters
per second per second so every second
that goes by so after one second I'm
going to go two meters per second faster
so I'll be at seven or another way to
think about it is the slope of this
velocity line is my constant
acceleration or I have a constant slope
here so it might look something it might
look something like that so what has
happened after four seconds so one two
three four so this is my delta T so my
final velocity is going to be right over
there so my final velocity is going to
be right over there I'll write it down
here just because it's getting in the
way of this word velocity and so this is
V this is my final velocity and what
would it be well I'm starting at five
meters per second so I'm going to do it
both using the variables and using the
concrete numbers so I'm starting at some
initial velocity I'm starting at some
initial velocity the subscript I says I
for initial and then each second that
goes by I'm getting this much faster so
if I want to see how much faster have I
gone I multiply the number of seconds
I'll just multiply the number of seconds
that go by times my acceleration times
times my acceleration and once again
this right here this is I just wrote the
subscript C saying that it's a constant
acceleration and so that will tell me
how fast I've gone if I take if I start
at this point and I multiplied the
duration times my slope I will get this
hi I will get to my final velocity I
will get to my final velocity and just
to make it clear what the numbers these
numbers really could be anything I'm
just picking these to make it concrete
in your mind you have five meters per
second plus four seconds plus I'm going
to do that in yellow plus four seconds
four seconds times our acceleration of
two meters per second squared two meters
per second squared and what is this
going to be equal to
you have a second canceling out with one
of the seconds down here you have four
times so let me write it so we have five
meters per second plus four times two is
eight eight this seconds gone we're just
left with meters per second eight meters
per second or this is the same thing as
13 meters per second which is going to
be our final velocity and I want to take
a pause here and you can pause and think
about it yourself this hopefully should
be intuitive we were starting at going
five meters per second every second that
goes by we're going to go two meters per
second faster so after one second we'll
be at 7 meters per second after 2
seconds we will be at 9 meters per
second after after 3 seconds we will be
at 11 meters per second and then after 4
seconds we will be at 13 meters per
second so you multiply how much time
pass
times acceleration this is how much
faster we're going to be going if we're
already going 5 meters per second 5 plus
how much faster 13 meters per second so
this right up here is 13 13 meters per
second so I'll take a little pause here
hopefully that's intuitive and now and
the whole point of that is to show you
that this formula that you'll often see
in many physics books it's not just
something that randomly popped out of
there it just makes complete common
sense now the next thing I want to talk
about is what is the total distance that
we would have traveled now we know from
the last video that distance is just the
area under this curve right over here so
it's just the area it's the area under
this curve you say well this is kind of
a strange shape right here how do I
calculate its area and we can just use a
little simple geometry to break it down
into two different areas that are very
easy to calculate their areas or that
there are two simple shapes you could
break it down into this blue part this
rectangle right over here easy to figure
out the area of a rectangle and we could
break it down into this purple part this
triangle right here easy to figure out
the area of a triangle and that will be
the total distance we travel and even
this will hopefully make some intuition
because this blue area is how far would
we have traveled if we were not
accelerating if we just went 5 meters
per second
for four seconds so if you go five
meters per second times so this is one
second two second three second four
second so you're going from zero set
time 0 to time for your change in time
is four seconds so if you go five meters
per second for four seconds you're going
to go 20 meters this right here is 20
meters that is the area of this right
here five times for this this this my
guess purple or magenta area tells you
how further than this are you going
because you're accelerating because you
kept going faster and faster and faster
and it's pretty easy to calculate this
area the check the base the base here is
still 5 because that's five seconds have
gone by and what's the height here the
height here is my final velocity minus
my initial velocity - my initial
velocity or it's the change in velocity
due to the acceleration and the change
in velocity to do the acceleration 13
minus five is eight or it's this eight
right over here it is eight it is eight
meters per second so this height right
over here is eight meters per second the
base right over here is fat and it sorry
it's four seconds that's the time that
passed so what's the area of this
triangle well area of a triangle is one
half times the base which is four
seconds four seconds times the height
which is eight meters per second times
eight meters per second seconds cancel
out 1/2 times 4 is 2 times 8 is equal to
is equal to 16 is equal to 16 meters so
the total distance we traveled is 20
plus 16 is 36 meters that is the total
or I could say the total displacement
and once again it's to the right since
it is positive so this is our
displacement now what I want to do is do
this exact same calculation but keep it
in variable form and that'll give
another formula that many people many
often memorize but I want you to
understand it it's a completely
intuitive formula and it just comes out
of the kind of the the logical flow of
reasoning that we went through this
video what is the area once again if we
use in the
if we just think about the variables
well the area of this of this rectangle
right here is our initial velocity times
our change in time times our change in
time so that's the blue this is the blue
rectangle right over here and then plus
what do we have to do we have the change
in time once again we have the change in
time times this height which is our
final velocity which is times our final
velocity minus our initial velocity
minus our initial velocity these are all
vectors oh they're just positive telling
us we're going to the right and if we
just don't multiply the base times the
height that would give us the area of
this entire rectangle we have to take it
by half because the triangle is only
half of that rectangle so times one-half
so times so times one-half and so this
is the area this is the purple area
that's not purple this is the purple
area right over here this is the area of
this this is the area of that and let's
simplify this a little bit let's factor
out a delta T so if you factor out a
delta T you get delta T times a bunch of
stuff V sub I so your initial velocity
your initial velocity we factor this out
Plus this stuff Plus this thing right
over here and we can distribute the 1/2
we factored we factored the 1/2 we Fest
sorry we factored the Delta T's out
that's what we picking it out and let's
multiply the 1/2 times each of these
things so it's going to be plus 1/2
times V F times our final velocity
that's not the right color let me
actually do it in the right color so
that you understand what I'm doing so
this is the 1/2 so plus 1/2 times our
final velocity final velocity minus 1/2
minus 1/2 times our initial velocity
minus 1/2 times our initial I want to do
that in blue sorry I'm having trouble
changing colors today minus 1/2 times
our initial velocity times our initial
velocity and now what does this simplify
to we have something plus 1/2 times
something else
-
1/2 times that original something so
what is VI minus 1/2 times VI so
anything minus half of it is you're
going to have a positive half left so
these two terms this term and this term
will simplify to will simplify to 1/2 V
I 1/2 the initial velocity plus 1/2
times the final velocity plus 1/2 times
the final velocity and all of that is
being multiplied by our change in all of
that is being multiplied by our change
in time or the time that has gone by and
this tells us this tells us the distance
the distance that we traveled or another
way to think about it let's factor out
this 1/2 let's factor out this 1/2 you
get distance is equal to change in time
times factoring out the 1/2 VI plus VF V
I know that's not the right color VI
plus VF plus VF so this is interesting
the distance we traveled is equal to 1/2
of the initial velocity plus the final
velocity so this is really if you just
took this quantity right over here is
just the arithmetic the I always have
trouble saying that word it's the
arithmetic mean of these two numbers and
so I'm going to define this as something
new I'm going to call this the average
velocity but we have to be very careful
with this this right here is the average
average velocity but the only reason why
I can just take the starting velocity
and the ending velocity and adding them
together and then divide by 2 is
essentially taking the average of these
two things which would be someplace over
here and I take that as the average
velocity is because my acceleration is
constant which is usually an assumption
in most introductory physics classes but
it's not always the assumption but if
you do have a constant acceleration like
this you can you can assume that the
average velocity is going to be the
average of the initial velocity and the
final velocity if this was a curve if
the acceleration was changing
you could not do that but what's useful
about this is if you want to figure out
the distance that was traveled you just
need to know the initial velocity and
the final velocity average the two and
then multiply that times the time that
goes by so in this situation our final
velocity is 13 meters per second our
initial velocity was 5 meters per second
so you have 13 plus 5 is equal to 18 you
divide that by 2 your average velocity
your average velocity is 9 meters per
second if you take the average of 13 and
5 and then 9 meters per second times 4
seconds gives you 36 meters so hopefully
that doesn't confuse you I just want to
show you where some of these things that
you'll see in your physics class some of
these formulas why you shouldn't
memorize them and they can all be
deduced